tom uh
home prices housing anything we need to
know with housing yeah i think but
people if you're trying to sell right
now and you have to sell let's say your
job is moving and you're looking at
potential recession you're looking at
things happening and you're looking like
you gotta move right now you i think you
just need to be realistic with what you
do at that house because we're seeing
houses i was just scanning markets and
not just south florida where we are down
here or dallas i was scanning like
phoenix i was scanning atlanta you know
in kind of northern areas of atlanta
where people have and houses are on the
market for a while and i noticed that
people haven't moved the price down but
i'm looking at houses that look
perfectly reasonable
you understand housing but they haven't
moved the price at all and then then i
look at zillow you can flip it over to
recent sales and i'm like man these
people either need to get realistic
about the price or maybe they're under
the loan and the financing underneath
they can't sell at the lower price
otherwise they have to
they'll be underwater they'll be
underwater contribute if you have to go
right now to another market you need to
get out and be realistic at what you can
get out and i hope you're not upside
down on on that but the and the other
thing is just statistically looking at
this
right now we've got a decline in home
sales that's accelerating it was three
percent decline now it's five percent
decline five point four percent decline
i think that the we're seeing the demand
run up a curve right now in other words
the net the the change in demand is
getting is accelerating at a rapid rate
remember at the beginning of the year
gas went like 350 national average 363
national average 375 national average
and all of a sudden it went to five
remember that big jump
that's the same thing if you're
listening and you're considering moving
home that's the same thing will happen
housing demand it drops three percent it
drops five percent all of a sudden the
report comes out that it's up 15
so if you got to sell your house you get
a roll right now if you're thinking
about buying a house right now i
wouldn't do it number one your
underlying mortgage is going to be
higher and number two i think you gotta
wait for those um the artificial equity
i call it you know as a result of two
trillion dollars pumped into the economy
has inflated housing prices artificially
and we got to wait for those to settle
back down so if you're looking to buy
right now and you're in even something
close to a reasonable lease hang with
the reasonable lease and look next
summer to buy i want to read something
here from a
moody's chief economist so you know how
moody's they don't have a you know
they're just kind of like giving you
what they think it is and fyi guys
whatever experts are saying right now
take it at
face value and do whatever you want to
do with it but you got to hear both
sides here's what he's saying mark
housing correction is dead ahead
warren's moody's chief economist mark
zandy
here's how he sees things playing out
over the next several months this is a
yahoo news story existing home sales
showed a 5.4 decline in june from may
but prices remain elevated according to
the national association of realtors the
median sale price of existing homes in
the u.s set a new record high of 416 in
june
marking a 13.4 percent increase from a
year ago
yet for those continuing to watch these
rising home prices chief economist
moody's anal analytics mark zandy warns
that a correction could be dead ahead
mortgage rates continue to climb as
interest rates rise further with some
forecasting and short-term rise of three
and a quarter on a 30-year fixed rate
loan mortgage rates are now sitting at
about six percent
as these rates rise mortgage payments
can be several thousand dollars higher
than they were a year ago zandy says and
this loss of affordability exactly why
he sees a correction in the near future
if we stay around six i think that the
market will adjust and we'll eventually
get that correction if it goes much
higher then we'll get a more significant
pullback in the housing market this is
what i'm talking about yeah so you have
a 5.4 percent drop in demand and the
interest rates are coming up yet the
prices are staying flat do you remember
the big short and there was a two-week
period on wall street where they talked
about why haven't the mark to market
remember why is the bond insurance gone
higher and this gone higher but the
underlying haven't and when it did it
did suddenly so you're seeing the demand
drop and the rates go up well prices are
holding steady those prices are under
stress because of the interest rates and
because the demand dropping and we're
going to i agree with this guy i think
dead ahead you're going to see a sudden
drop in the purchase it's and i think
it's going to be slowly than suddenly
let me just say something i i think um
we talk about the importance of
diversifying where you get
your information we talk about that in
regards to politics all the time we do
say hey if i watch something on cnn i'll
also flip over to fox i don't watch
actual tv i'm talking about youtube i'll
watch clips on msnbc
you know cnbc msnbc fox cnn uh the whole
the whole lot the whole gamut to get a
variety of opinions and then you can
decide for myself
much is the same that where i how i view
my financial advice so
there's like if you only got your advice
from realtors what are realtors going to
tell you it's a great time to buy
things are always going to go up if
you're if you're only interested in the
stock market you know of course you need
a financial advisory of course you need
someone to manage your money of course
you need to be reinvesting of course you
need to buy the of course like if you're
only talking to somebody who does crypto
it's like bitcoins going to the moon how
would you know you got to get it on
bitcoin you got don't get don't get
cheap don't get it
so like
it's just
depending on where you get your news is
what you're going to hear so it's
important to kind of hear a a a variety
of sources so you're not influenced to
going down what someone else wants you
to to do because it benefits their
bottom line yeah i can't tell you how
many realtors i get interested in like
i'm not a big real net real estate guy
although i invest in reits you're
familiar with reports right you can own
real estate without actually having to
get your hands dirty i'm a big fan of
that okay any time that i do something
here on the pbd podcast or i'm like look
i think kind of buying for most people
is a little overrated hold on shocker
alert depending on where you're at in
life so if you're young if you're single
if you're flexible if you want to have
mobility if you don't you talked about
if you're living in phoenix maybe you're
moving in austin maybe you move miami i
don't know where i'm going stay flexible
like this guy just came from california
the first thing i said to him is like
you've been here about 15 [ __ ]
minutes don't buy right now just rent
okay yeah but at the same time there's
certain people that have families they
have school districts they have you know
they want to
be in a sense of a community they're not
moving anywhere for five ten years cool
bye so but it's always the people that
are like
joe blow real estate bill you know
realtor they're always like you don't
know what you're talking about bro it's
like
by your instagram name i can already
tell you that you're not going to want
to hear what i have to say yeah right
because you're
bill realtor yeah okay
johnny mortgage guy what do you expect
to say when someone talks [ __ ] about
your marketplace that's like pat and i
are in the insurance world right so
there's a lot of people that say you
know they're termites don't buy don't
buy universal life don't buy iul it's a
waste of money by term invest the
difference how many times you've heard
that dave ramsey always talks about that
yep so
but at the same time if you interview a
million different insurance agents
they'll tell you the benefits of buying
permanent insurance rather than term
right so just be very careful where you
get your information is what i took from
it diversify the content you consume
okay
diversify the council you're getting on
financial advice diversified i don't
think that's a bad i think that's
actually very good council
being given to everybody that's
listening to this so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]